Located at the Sawgrass Mills Mall is a place where every Barbie fan...
...can live out their fantasy.
Hi, I'm Kelly for VisitFlorida, and today,...
...we're at the first ever Barbie Dream House Experience,...
...where you and I get to step inside her world.
The iconic dream house comes to life in a 10,000-square-foot interactive experience.
You can spend the day, host your very own fashion show,...
...or even celebrate your birthday here.
Barbie.
The wonderful thing about Barbie The Dream House Experience,...
...it is great for fans of every age.
As soon as you walk in, you are greeted by one of Barbie's friends.
And Barbie's friend will take you throughout the dream house.
Barbie's kitchen has a cupcake island where you'll be able to make a virtual cupcake.
From there, you'll go into her freezer...
...and you'll be able to ride a sleigh while watching a Barbie webisode.
There are so many things to discover.
There are seven different rooms in total within the Barbie Dream House Experience.